[Music]
let's go to mandy in raleigh north
carolina what's up mandy
hi john how are you doing today i am
dancing like i've never danced before
i'm dancing on the ceiling
what's up i feel ya i'm the same yeah i
uh
i have just received a really awesome
job offer very cool um higher pay actual
benefits compared to what i have now
um and i'm excited about it it's
tentative they're probably going to give
me a firm offer not sure yet
dude you are
you are
oh man i just asked the girl out and she
said yes we're gonna get married i just
haven't she hasn't fully said yes yet
but she said she would respond to my
texts tomorrow i haven't really even
asked yet but i'm thinking about it's
gonna be so good
well in this context with the type of
job it is it's a tentative means i'll
get it on if i pass background checks so
and i don't have any skeletons in my
closet that i know of have you ever been
to jail
i sure have not so thank goodness what a
boring life just kidding good for you
man good for you okay so you're getting
this job offer
we're celebrating here everybody let's
all cheer back there in the booth cheer
can't hear him but all right so we're
all excited for you but it sounds like
there's a
wow
there's a butt
currently i work for a family firm
i am one of two professionals in this
firm
and i nurture a ton of client
relationships i manage a ton of highly
billable projects and i handle crisis
situations for my boss family member
pretty frequently so very valuable in
this firm you know has two professionals
in it me and my family member and
this is a significant pay raise this is
super great benefit i cannot say no to
this offer but i am going to let down my
family like there's no tomorrow
who's your family member
my in-laws i worked my in-laws oh no
yep what's that are you just talking
about an in-law situation before this
yes
y'all don't live in the same apartment
do you
oh no no no no no no okay good
absolutely not that would have made this
call so much more awesome um
what's the what's the business what's
the firm
um i am a professional accountant i'm a
cpa
kappa all right so you are a cpa
in a family tax firm an accounting firm
do they make more money and they just
not pay you or is this just as much as
they make
we don't really talk about it i'm an
employee that's it i'm an employee on a
salary that's it i love it dude it's so
great so you're not a partner at this
accounting firm or anything no
absolutely not oh i'm so happy
who's the other accountant please say
your father-in-law
yes oh sweet
dude so two cool things are gonna happen
number one you're gonna make a jillion
more dollars and get benefits and
you don't have christmas plans this year
that's so great
[Laughter]
let's have more fun do you have uh kids
yes yes how many
one one
is it
please tell me it's the only grandkid
please please please please please
yes oh yes
you're gonna ruin everything
mandy i know
everything
i'm so happy
listen i don't get these kind of calls
very often they're all sad and
depressing you're gonna blow up your
whole family and i'm so excited okay so
obviously i'm i'm laughing because you
okay you know you have to do this
yes do your does your family have any
idea
no none not not not this side of the
family no my my mom knows about it but
that's it
and my husband obviously okay that's
what i was going to ask
has he been keeping this from his
parents
yes yes
yikes
so that's where i think this is going to
get dicey because they've treated you
like an employee
you are an employee on a salary
you get to make grown up employee
choices for your employee self you're
not a partner you're not you do a lot
for that business and they pay you for
what you do right yeah and so that's all
good
i'm minimizing this this is going to be
a big thing
where i think this is going to be a
challenge is if i'm them i would ask
why didn't you tell us you felt
underpaid
why didn't you at least come talk to us
about this what about this
oh you have okay so tell me about those
conversations
um we don't do performance based um it's
mostly a salary um i've my opinion is i
have really high billable hours the
opinion of
the the partner my father-in-law is i
don't
cool that's great
so
here's
this is this is
one
i'm so happy will you promise before i
tell you anything else you promise
you'll call me back and let me know how
this goes please please please
i will i gotta know how this goes even
if next time you're crying and you're
like they like they hate us and whatever
i just got to know how this thing ends
um
one time i was just flipping channels i
love stand-up comedy i'm kind of
obsessed with it and i don't remember
the name of this comedian but i just
stopped by and this comedian was talking
about driving down the street and it was
like on a telephone pole and he saw one
of those signs it said call this number
and ask me how i lost weight
and
he called it and said hey i'm just
calling to ask you how you lost weight
and then
instead of it being some advertisement
that god the joke was the guy just said
diet and exercise thanks
and hung up so that made me laugh and i
thought that was a hilarious joke
and so i'm telling you the same thing
this is simple advice that's impossible
it's so hard but you know you got to do
it
and that is you need to tell your
father-in-law
hey um
we need to have a hard conversation
about work
and can we schedule that and he'll
probably say well let's just do it right
now so you may want to
send him an email you may want to
um i hate to say this we may want to
even shoot him a text but my guess is he
loves you and he cares about you and
he's your boss
and
he's going to want to have that
conversation right then
do you all have i'm sure you don't have
one-on-one meetings or anything like
that huh
i mean it's it's small i mean we sit and
talk you know just him and i a lot i
mean
so
we have pretty open conversation
between us it's just gotten a little
tint
in the past few months
over this work situation
well how come
um
i'm ready to grow yeah i'm ready to do
more okay um but i'm still treated i
mean i've been practicing for
almost half a decade and um
how old are you even though
i'm 26. oh you just said that like a 26
year old i've been doing this for half a
decade or five years
[Music]
you said that like in the most
maximum way
i've been doing this a better part of a
decade which is like five years in one
day um yeah so you got five years
experience that's cool
how long has he been doing this
uh 30. okay so let's let's call what
what let's be honest about the whole
thing he's got way more experience than
you is that fair oh yeah been doing this
a long time is that fair
yes and this is his business that's fair
yes yes he can do whatever he wants and
he's got to treat you with dignity
and you can too
you can too i needed that john well you
can't i mean you're a grown-up and this
is a weird situation i don't like
i don't like this
the only group i've ever seen do it
really well is
dave ramsey and his kids and his in-laws
they all everybody works in the bus not
all of them but many of them work in the
business
and they are super clear they call him
dave at work they call him dad at home
they don't talk about work at home they
leave all the stuff here very clear job
descriptions very clear performance
metrics and that's that's the way you
got to do it you got to be overly clear
when you mix family business you don't
have that and that's great and cool
man you want to go back to just being
daughter-in-law where he can dote on you
and do it on your kids and you all can
make jokes about your husband together
and
y'all do whatever at the holidays
um
yeah it's time for you to grow so you
just need to have a grown-up been doing
this for half a decade conversation
which is going to be hard uncomfortable
here's a couple of tips for that
say less than you think
okay
all right are you gonna write this down
i am i'm a notetaker of course you are
you're an accountant say less than you
think you don't need to go into a bunch
of explanations i've been asking for
this
you don't need to do that
you need to say
i've accepted another position at
a another tax firm it's a significant
pay increase it's just a different level
of
of um
uh responsibility i'm so grateful that
you
got me off the ground i'm grateful for
the experience i've had
learning here but
don't say all that stuff because then if
he is any kind of boss he's going to say
i'll help you grow i'll he'll start
backfilling your reasons you don't need
to give him those
your reasons are your reasons
all you owe him
is
the dignity of a face-to-face
conversation
not leaving him like if you've got all
these clients not just walking out of
there in 10 days like say i will commit
to i will leave with integrity
i will transfer these relationships et
cetera but here's my end date
and um
i hope i
i look forward to just being your
daughter-in-law
and going from there
and then he here's the thing
he has the responsibility to be the
adult in this situation be a be an adult
also not the be an adult too
hear me very carefully write this down
and put stars around it and circle it
okay you are not responsible for his
response
okay your job isn't to make it okay for
him your job isn't to make sure his his
his little heart is not sad
he gets to choose to be angry he gets to
choose to be sad
he gets to choose to have any kind of
response he may breathe a sigh of relief
and say oh thank god i just i didn't we
were kind of here now and i didn't know
what was next
probably probably not but maybe
you cannot own his response
it will be fair i think
for him to feel like y'all hid this from
him
and
yeah
it will be fair for him to understand
there wasn't a lot of i mean
if you'd come to him and said hey i'm
looking for another job that would have
been weird too
yeah well it's a high pressure i mean
it's always high pressure where we are
october 15th is our biggest deadline
yeah you know with the personal tax
extension so i've been waiting until
after this date
to talk to him and i haven't gotten the
firm offer yet but i am not it's a 99
chance i will so i might not even have
this conversation if it's one percent
but
yeah if it's not just bring donuts and
be like here we are and then back to
working with excellence but talk less
um
say hey i need 30 minutes of your time i
need 15 minutes of your time don't start
backpedaling don't start getting into i
just need a chance to grow it this is a
great opportunity financially this is a
great opportunity for you and your
family this is a um
it's got some neat new responsibilities
and you are so grateful for the
opportunity they gave you period in a
vet sentence
here is um
let silence be your friend not your
enemy in this conversation
yep i'm somebody who talks too much the
past year i've been learning the value
of silence
when i worked with lawyers i learned
this statement
the power and the pause
he who speaks first loses
yep
that that's lawyer talk for how they
engage one another
he who speaks first loses
there's power in the pause
and a lot of that talking talking
talking talking comes from
a lack of self-confidence
yep
from insecurity
you've been doing this for half a decade
half a decade
it's just the most millennial way to say
something um
i've been doing this for like a thousand
days oh you mean two and a half years
yes or three and a half years um
own your decision own your choice it is
gonna cause some challenges
hopefully he responds maturely what do
you think you think he's gonna respond
maturely or no
honestly i don't know
you do you've been working with him for
half a decade okay there's two different
ways he could respond one could be okay
great go take the opportunity this would
be great because he thinks that i don't
have enough billable hours anyways um
even though i have data to prove
otherwise but
you might be like okay cool awesome and
then after i leave you can be like oh
crap um and then
uh or or he'll say well what can i do to
match it we'll tell you to match it what
can i do to keep you because we need you
um so that's those are probably two's
responses either one taking it
gracefully saying cool awesome go we'll
transition you out
um or
what can i do magic what can i do to
match it like like very frantic okay so
have you run that scenario in your mind
i'm just gonna tell them the decisions
made
if i'm you i would say i'm ready to go
just be your daughter-in-law
yeah i'm ready to go be your
daughter-in-law i like that okay i'm
ready just to be the mom of your
grandkid and the wife of your husband
and
a competitor in your community and we're
going to run you out of business old man
prepare to be crushed you can say that
too but i wouldn't but that'd be awesome
i won't be a competitor so it's a
different kind of job
a different kind of job
so yeah i'm ready to speak i'm ready to
go back to being your daughter-in-law
and i'm so grateful for you and
appear in that sentence and then power
and the pause you don't have anything
else to say
all right that helps and you promised in
front of america and even some listeners
in germany and russia because evidently
we got those now too
um
that you're going to call me back and
let me know how this conversation goes
and let me know call me about a week
into your new first your first new job
okay
okay hey congratulations we we are
cheering you on
and if you end up with no thanksgiving
and christmas plans nashville is an
awesome place to visit congratulations
mandy
talk less be direct be honest
you've worked for half a decade
you got the rest of your life for this
guy to be your father-in-law